i guarantee you i will never let it
slide
i will never let it slide even if i
don't retrieve my money this guy needs
to be stopped
it's [ __ ] crazy the reason for that
is when you rob for a long time
especially for a couple years it gets to
a point where you think it's so easy
that you
you leave many traces you leave for this
guy he's leaving every trace
so he either ameritrade is lying or
incompetent or
he faked a wire transfer of
eight hundred thousand somewhere in that
range i definitely think that one
million percent faked it
one hundred percent are you willing to
go to court about that
oh i would uh i think this is bigger
than the court case
[Music]
everybody's having a great evening so
i'm getting emails and dm requests
regarding bitcoin if i'm still buying
bitcoin
not what rate because the price rose so
i'm still buying bitcoin at market price
plus
five percent over a lot of people ask me
oh why are you paying five percent over
why can't you just buy from the exchange
i'm disabled from
certain platforms of buying because i
bought too much
so if anybody wants to sell no matter
what the quantity is
um send me a dm i'll be buying ladies
and gentlemen welcome to 221c baker
street home of the internet detective i
am your host coffeezilla and today we
are talking to
the victims of jay mazzini
now this is a very serious video because
there are
literally millions of dollars on the
line just in this one video
about a million dollars was defrauded
via bitcoin these people have not
received the money they were promised as
you guys saw in the trailer
jay mazzini has been promising you know
to buy bitcoin over market value but
the victims say he never paid them we're
going to be hearing from them
today as a reminder it's all allegation
but
we're trying to make sure that justice
prevails here please watch
share and subscribe and make sure that
no one ever falls for this guy
again now our two victims today are
waffy and ahmed
we will be hearing from both of them one
of them lost about 200 000
the other 750 thousand
dollars it's an incredible amount and
the story is is that many more people
were burned by this same scheme
interestingly
our last story on james yesterday got
quite a lot of buzz and he even
responded to it
saying in a story quote uh easy to
target someone that has a big name
audience but the truth
will prevail well i'm certainly hoping
so
jay without further ado let's talk to
the victims
and unravel this scheme together it's
been the 7th of january i sent him
5.049 btc
uh from my company account in montreal
and i still haven't received it can i
ask you why you did that did you think
he was going to be a quick way to make
some money because of his situation or
he gave he provided with full kyc right
so he provides with
passport i told myself who would be
stupid enough
to burn someone for almost a quarter
million canadian and
give his full identity because it's
really him uh have him on facetime
i have him on facetime i sent you some
proof
to be clear he sent you his passport
with like everything
showing the fact that it is a hundred
percent him who did this deal
listen it's a hundred percent in between
is not someone that tried to impersonate
him
and in my head i told myself who with
such
visibility uh and popularity or whatever
followers he has even though it could be
fake and that he sends his full
full name full password he means it's
him you get it
yeah yeah he's stupid enough to do so i
don't know what he's going through
in his life maybe to burn people like
that he's playing games with people
and he played with the wrong guy because
i'm gonna do
everything in my possible to get him
stopped to retrieve my funds
and to protect others from this guy
because it's a real hassle to get your
money back after
[Music]
my personal experience with them was
i had someone who told me he was looking
for bitcoins paying five percent over
market price
and it was weird to me because it was
for me it's as easy as go on your
exchange press buy and
get it so i text him on instagram he
facetime he asked me for my phone number
he facetimes me
starts showing me bank accounts and it's
obviously really hit it's obviously
really
really him right yeah it's 100 him um
because a lot of these bitcoin scams are
done by faceless accounts
it's one million percent him i have
everything directly from him
um from his id passport email
one million percent him everything's
documented from a to z
i mean the guy's robbing people face to
face and i think
the reason for that is when you rob for
a long time
especially for a couple years it gets to
a point where you think it's so easy
that you
you you leave many traces you leave for
this guy he's leaving every trace
so he calls me via facetime starts
showing me uh
crypto accounts with a lot of money
shows me
um shows me confirmation on his
how much money are we talking about he
was showing me uh
he was claiming a 30 plus million in net
net worth
which following following
discovering that he had defrauded me
when i looked
into his past the guy was running a hat
shop
i ran i personally ran a company with 76
employees
in order to generate a multi-million
dollar revenue
then you look at a guy out of a hat shop
who claims that 30 million dollar net
worth and his hat shop
if you look on his instagram it dates
back to like two years oh yeah
it's nothing but it just doesn't it's
not feasible you have to
it's just impossible in this country to
do so
without seeing uh something fishy
happening
but this this is the he was running
giveaway scans before that to even
exactly traffic i'll be doing another
giveaway 200 winners
giving them ten thousand dollars each
this is me discovering uh following me
but when i did when i did the
transaction with him he showed me
uh he gave me um a screenshot showing
that he did 27 million with withdrawals
out of his stock investment account in
mary trade
showed me live his bitcoin accounts with
a lot of money
so i said sure let's go ahead and i'll
send you an invoice
it was this it was we met on a friday
night he was really pressuring me to
give him bitcoins like he was
calling me every 15 minutes talking
about his wife and him wanting to
fly down and meet with me and and hang
out and everything so
i send them about 18 000 20 000
worth of bitcoins over the weekend
that's what i was able to send and i
told them to wait until monday to get
them a large amount
so by monday i had contacted the
exchange and had
and wired them uh almost eight hundred
thousand dollars 750
ish wired them that money so they can
send
and they sent the bitcoins directly to
the address he's provided he confirmed
receiving the bitcoins on monday
and uh following when
when he confirmed receiving them he
issued a
bank wire um which when you issue bank
wire it's basically a
look at it as a certified check you
can't cancel a a bank choir
because i've the only payment method i
do for large transactions is bank wires
always done i'm done thousands of them
so when i got his bank receipt i was
like okay
the only way this guy could get me is if
he literally cancelling
the wire and commits wire fraud and why
would anybody commit wire fraud
face-to-face
you know if you give me a certified
check and i have your passport i have
the full evidence against you
why would you go and and give me a fake
certified check
so that's what he did to me basically he
gave me a wire that i then discovered
was fake because i called the married
trade no
um that was those on a monday i called
the married trade which is the sending
senders bank that he gave me
confirmation on i called him tuesday and
i'm like hey where's this wire
they're like give it another 24 hours
max they said it should have been done
monday
they gave it another 24 hours max i
called on wednesday
they're like honestly that wire doesn't
they don't see anything they're like
delaware doesn't exist so
he either ameritrade is lying or
incompetent or he
faked a wire transfer of 800
000 somewhere in that range oh
definitely faked it one million percent
faked it
100 are you willing to go to court about
oh i that uh i think this is bigger than
the court case this this is a national
this is a national um because he's doing
this to a lot of people this is a
homeland security
national fraud case this is much bigger
than i think this isn't a lawsuit where
i'm gonna wait five years
i need the world to know that this guy
has defrauded
we're estimating over 22 million dollars
that it has been defrauded
me as a victim i have enough evidence
from my case
which is i've been defrauded under wire
fraud fifth by deception
and i received also not only did he give
me a a fee wire transfer
he gave me an additional fake wire
transfer on wednesday
for an uh for saying i'm gonna res reset
the wire
right then thursday that wire doesn't
arrive
then between thursday and friday i
receive another fake confirmation of
bitcoin
confirmation that never that's never
been received
so when when you're playing with someone
who's now he's saying he never got the
money
the bitcoin no he did he did he
confirmed receiving them 100
no no i know but you said he's generated
a fake bitcoin
confirmation or something oh when he so
what his
initial fake wire transfer then arrived
he said there's a second wire transfer
he's sending out
right that didn't arrive he said okay
i'm gonna go ahead and send it to you in
bitcoins
i'm like sure i'll take bitcoins then
when when i go ahead to receive a
bitcoins i receive another fake
confirmation
then we go on you want to play with the
thief you want to play there there
you want to play along right you want to
see where where this heads do
so i'm like okay this this is a fake
this is a fake
um this is a fake confirmation then he
as criminals when when you
when you quarter them and show them that
they they you know exactly what they're
up to
they try to attack you back and say you
you're doing this you're doing that
you're a bullshitter you're this and
they start cursing you out and stuff and
i for me i don't disrespect doesn't
isn't gonna get him out of this
situation right simply i said i need my
money back that you stole from me
you face-to-face defrauded me using a
fake wire transfer that never arrived
at least giving money back and i might
still be willing to walk away
then he said okay i'll send it to you
brother um give me a bit until i get
home whatever
i wait he gets home i stay up till 3 4
a.m
i'm stressed out
he's stringing you along i wake up the
next day i'm like hey
still don't see the the coins he says
give me a bit brother i'm getting ready
i'll send it to you shortly and um then
i don't see it then three hours later
says he's going to his fat
mom's house then says i'll send it when
i get back home when i'm like my pc
then that was like five days ago doesn't
the fact that he keeps telling you that
like oh i'm gonna send it
doesn't that mean he's admitting that
the wire transfers were fake
he admitted he admitted being um so in
our conversations
he's claiming that the why that the bank
delayed his funds or
some [ __ ] excuses that that are not
real um
but when when it comes down when you
send me this can you send me the money
can you send me those texts
oh i have i have a full i mean i have
everything is documented
what i say is 100 documented and he
knows i've documented everything which
makes me
which makes me concerned how could you
be such a stupid scammer that you're
scamming someone face to face
they're telling you they're documenting
you and you're still going all the way
in
it's bizarre it's totally bizarre and i
think it's gotten to that point because
if you get away with over 20 million
dollars
he's probably doped up he thinks all
this money is gonna
save him it doesn't work we're in a
country where if you rob a billion
dollars
in europe you go offshore you're getting
caught and this guy thinks
because a lot of people are patient and
took on his games he thinks the next
victim might take it on you're doing a
public service by taking this guy down
um he there's obviously 22 other people
just like you who've lost
crazy amounts of money there's more bro
it's sickening i
i'm constantly getting dms we will take
the guy down 100
and i will cooperate with media um with
the government with
anybody that needs any information
because i have a really large
evidence file on it documented
everything and
i'm more than happy to share as long as
people out there
are aware of what's happening because
it's a serious amount of money we're not
talking
half a million dollars a hundred
thousand dollars serious amount yep
it's extremely serious thank you ahmad
thank you for your time
appreciate you thank you
i know what you need this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick trying to sell
me on a dream but that was where you
lost me
wake up and smell the coffee